it's a reason thank you uh thank you mr
speaker can i thank my right honourable
friend
for his statement the government appears
resigned to the prospect of no deal
yet one area in which they should not be
resigned to the prospect of no deal
is insecurity i note that my right
honourable friend made no mention of
security in his statement this afternoon
and the prime minister made no reference
to security in his letter to
parliamentarians on the 16th of october
so will my right honourable friend
confirm that if the uk
walks away with no deal then our police
and other law enforcement agencies
will no longer have the necessary access
to databases such as pnr
in order to be able to continue to
identify and catch
criminals and potential terrorists in
order to keep us safe
[Music]
well my right honourable friend um makes
a very important point about security i
say three things
i think the first thing to say is that a
significant progress has been made in
respect of security cooperation
but it is the case that the eu are
insisting that before we have access to
systems
like the schengen information system too
that we have to accept the jurisdiction
of the european court of justice
we cannot accept that the second thing i
would say
is that there are many many areas in
which we can cooperate more effectively
to safeguard our borders outside the
european union than we ever could
inside through a variety of methods and
arrangements
open to us open to border force and open
to our security and intelligence
services
we can intensify the security that we
give to the british people
and the third thing i would say to the
right honourable lady is that i agree
with her
when it comes to everything security and
other matters no deal is better than a
bad deal